how does the decision-making process in
the Council of the European Union work
well the council is one of the three
main institutions of the EU with the
Commission and the Parliament it is
composed of national government
ministers from each of the 28 member
states ministers represent the interests
of their own democratically accountable
governments the council in the
parliament consider amend negotiate and
adopt EU legislation normally proposed
by the commission that is the ordinary
legislative procedure also known as
co-decision it sounds simple but it's
not that easy under the ordinary
legislative procedure the council and
the Parliament are on equal footing if
they reach agreement they can adopt the
legislation at first reading if not
there is a second reading if following
the second reading the two institutions
still can't agree a conciliation
committee is convened since 1999
sixty-seven percent of ordinary
legislative procedure files have been
concluded during the first reading
twenty-four percent during the second
reading and only nine percent through
conciliation
there are two other procedures used for
a few specific cases the consent
procedure and the consultation procedure
once adopted certain types of EU
legislation then have to be incorporated
international law some are directly
applicable others take some time to
become law for the 500 million citizens
of the EU how can ministers hold their
national jobs and sit in the council
well they get a little help all the work
of the council is prepared or
coordinated by the permanent
representatives committee known as Cora
/ Cora / is made up of member state
representatives in addition the council
has more than 150 working parties and
committees who also help few those
ministers are human after all in short
that's how decision-making in the
Council of the EU works find out more on
the website at Consilium shrubbery you